For me that was always the criterion and
I thought you had to look like that to
be a fitness creator. I
think that maybe that
has changed. I don't know anymore or if it's just me or
just me that sees it that way, but I think it has
totally changed and what I
see as a trend right now is exactly the
opposite and I think
that's how it's developing,
people who are more real and
show things that maybe aren't so perfect are
growing extremely warmly
welcome to the OMR podcast  an episode
that probably makes me
feel a bit old at times because I only
noticed the phenomenon of growing pineapples relatively late, but
I'm still curious and there's something new
in this country BZ it comes from
Austria actually it comes from
Austria today is what do you call it  you
elich growing pineapple Anna engelschall as a
guest hello Anna hello
thank you very much I'm really happy
to be here, I'm still a little bit
excited, I'm a listener and it's
amazing what other people are
sitting here, well you are now too  with
the scope of your story it's
really crazy what you've been saying recently when did it really start
with you so when do
you feel like you got into this job so
I
started a few years ago but really
the first breakthrough came with the first
Lockdown Corona hasn't been that
long yet, but how many years has it been since
the lockdown in 2020? Well, it's been a
lockdown for three years, yes, and before that
you were a software developer, you're a
computer scientist, yes, I
did the training, and I
worked in mine for four years  Not
a completely normal job but I could
always work from there
as I wanted
but and that you were at the company in
Austria exactly in the softwarefma
in Vienna in Graz in Graz okay and then
you somehow had the feeling
Now with the lockdown, something
new has to be done and then you started
uploading your sports fitness videos to YouTube, it started a little differently
and back then I've always really
loved
doing sports, so I was always after
work, I was always ready  I
always go to training for training and
that really fascinated me
back then. I don't know if you
know CrossFit, tell you what, yes, I
fell in love with this whole CrossFit
principle and then I
also thought I wanted
CrossFit  Suddenly becoming a coach and so
it started very slowly and
I also shared a bit of the whole CrossFit journey
online
and so I slowly slipped into this
social mediawt so you have to
say I haven't
seen any videos from anyone
The preparation told me that you were
extremely small and slim and
thin back then, so you
weighed under a kilo when it started, exactly that
was before and that was
then that I discovered CrossFit
and that was also my first little one
Viral story I would say
of this skinny under the and the
weight of very very thin and then
you built muscle from there you have to
imagine it like this I went
into this CrossFit gym for the first time in this
CrossFit box and for  For me, there was
always just sport to lose weight and to
become thinner and just to
be skinny and then I come
into this CrossFit gym for the first time
and see all these strong women and
suddenly it wasn't
about how thin they were  do you have to look how
thin do you have to be but it was about
completely different values, completely different things
namely that you have to have energy and
be strong and that really
fascinated me and that's why I
suddenly wanted to be strong and then
you always have this journey  Documented
and on YouTube or on whatever channel
Instagram Instagram Stories
mainly I
may have posted a few photos from time to time
back then, but more like that for
women. There
wasn't really any
thought behind it that I
wanted to do this professionally now, but
I slowly shared the story, yes,
and what caused it to
take off so much? Now there are videos of
you that have over 100 million
views, so they are the particularly good ones, but
still those are numbers, they are
no longer normal at all, so that's okay
no longer family, so what
were the
booster positions, so maybe you still have to
say that it
actually took years, but
years, so three and a half years is
n't that long for a career like that,
but
I still had to do a lot of things  I also
tried out a lot of things that didn't
work,
I slowly got to grips with which
videos worked or which hooks
at the beginning, what do you have to do at the beginning
to produce viral content, so tried out a lot
of things, tried a lot to
understand my audience,
listened to it, and got a lot of feedback from me
yes and then I slowly
approached it and now at the moment I
think I have already found my formats
that work quite well, that's
exactly what I'm continuing to do. I would have
the feeling from the outside that when I
first noticed the story, that
it's you, it's often like that  You need
some new platform that has a D
in particular, there are a lot of
influencers who grew up because
they used to be on Instagram or the
early YouTubers grew up because
they used to be on YouTube and so
on and you weren't a completely
new one  Platform there but it was like this
these YouTube shorts these
short videos or something like that that means there
was a new
content offer on the existing platform and I had the
suspicion you have to say whether that
could have helped you a lot on this
platform within the platform so to speak  to have been
very present, definitely
short form content generally everywhere
on Instagram also tiktok but also
YouTube shorts definitely I
discovered my love for it there too
so I have an incredible amount of
fun producing this shot content
so how long is the video  from
you because in the short V videos
how long woah so 30 seconds
sen 26 seconds to 30 seconds but
above all you have made such a
name for yourself over
these over these 30
seconds no actually not so the
actual boost so  The actual thing
came with the walkout videos on
YouTube in the first lockdown and that
was long form okay okay that means you
started with the lockdown and
or then things immediately progressed in big
steps yes I had
a video back then you have to  I have to say that it went
viral with the first lockdown.
I can remember that
all the gyms closed like that back then
and then suddenly this
one video came out that was older, that
was 2 years old and then I had no
idea, 8000 views and  It
suddenly had 200,000 overnight
and then it went up to 300,000
suddenly it had millions. That
was also a CrossFit home workout and there
was really nothing on
YouTube, that means all the crossfitters were
then maybe okay, I want to make the video
now and  That was my
push on YouTube again where I
thought okay, I have to use that now
and I also posted from Dahan every
day. That lasted for a very long time. I
uploaded a video to YouTube every day and then always did a
workout like that  half an hour or so
or exactly every day a new
workout of half an hour and
then you produced it yourself or do
you already have a cameraman or a
camerawoman or how do you have to
imagine, no, I filmed that alone,
I also took a very long time  I
edited it for a long time, so I edited it myself, I
don't do it myself anymore, I did it myself for a long time and
then Aon was the
first to come on board, she helped me a
bit to organize the whole thing,
then upload it, later
then Fabian with the editing, okay but
During this whole lockdown period,
you were still working at another job,
no, I wasn't there anymore,
I was already full-time, I was already
full-time in this social media and
YouTube thing, when did you
decide to do it full-time, so
with what reach or  When do
you start when or was it just like that right at the
beginning after I want it now I don't give
a [ __ ] whether it works or
not no as I said at the beginning so at the
very beginning just Instagram with my
stories and everyone got a bit
carried away then you got it  Maybe
a cooperation like that and I don't know
anymore then you made a little bit of
money from it, but I
quit my job relatively early and
even though I could
n't have made a good living from it, you have to be
honest, but I made a relatively
good living  saved and earned well at the time. That's
exactly when I quit
my job in a relatively risky way, I would say,
and started doing it slowly, but
YouTube wasn't an issue at the time, but you
already knew that I actually wanted
to become an influencer now, at the time I
quit before that  not and
you also knew that it was a business, so you
could make a good living from it.
At the beginning I was perhaps a
bit naive and a bit
naïve, yes, I would like to do it,
I would like to do it, so there was a
risk involved, but what  Did you
think what you could earn with that? I do
n't know. I
just wanted to be able to make a living from it. That was
my intention, so now not
no dimension, ir 4000 € a year SAS
somehow. I don't know what I
was thinking back then. I want to
just earn enough money that I
can move out, that I can travel. The end
mhm and now the truth is that an
incredible amount of money comes in, it's always a
little different and we can make a good living from it,
that means I've been
able to fulfill this little dream that I  Being able to
hire employees
was always my biggest dream. I
now have three full-time employees and
freelancers, and that makes me
really happy. I'm
incredibly grateful for this job, that
I can build up such a small team
and I think it's the coolest
job  have as a team and now tell me
briefly your reach so that you can grab a
bit so on Instagram
how big your account I have to
think for a moment 1.3 million are now on
insta
YouTube is the largest and the
fastest growing at the moment with
4  .24 million right now and it's all
more of an attic space or is international
so cross-platform
tiktok we are also
relatively large with
1.2 million and across
Germany is definitely the largest
and otherwise international so the USA comes
next and then what
Maybe France is also quite exciting, hmm I have
no idea why they are so
interested but you do
n't speak D in the videos either or
I mean you don't speak French
but or exactly the workout videos
are completely without speaking and
sometimes there is
a little intro in front of them  comes or
after that a short one in English yes and
most of the content is in
English because you consciously want the
largest possible target groups to be
reached. A good question is
why and it also comes very often from the
community why do you
always speak in
English woah  I think that
started my team we work Inter
so we work internationally also
my three full-time employees two
of them one is from Australia the
other is from the
USA we speak everything in English as well as
internationally why are they so
international so your team why do you have them
there  People who are the first employees,
I had a really great
luck with Marcel Marcel, who
is with me today, my manager, that's exactly
his girlfriend and I think we
both had a
conversation like that. I was alone and I was there
Lockdown fought and we both
saw okay, I need someone else,
I need someone very quickly
and somehow it worked out
and I would say through net through the
perfect network through Marcel I
met Er and she then
started working full-time with me  and the
American through eren also okay okay
Alana yes and also through the network
this from Germany but and when did
you decide on the name so
growing pineapple is now
pretty wild as a name actually growing pineapple
that was also a bit like that I have
Before that, at some point
I think my name was Fitness Anna or Anna
Fitness on Instagram,
but then somehow when the
topic came up: I need a new
name if I want to do something and
then somehow, I don't remember
exactly, it started to grow  Pineapple wild
story with pineapples and with the
pineapples to eat yes yes and growing
I always thought growing was always really cool was always
what I wanted in
CrossFit back then I wanted to
grow muscles and I also wanted to
grow as a person myself and then it somehow
worked out  with growing pineapples at some point
it was growing pineapples everywhere okay
okay how are you today 28 28 okay now
you have found your dream job a
bit and how do you have to
imagine everyday life how many videos do
you make a day today every day is a
little different  So today, for example,
I'm not making a video at all because we're here in
Hamburg, but otherwise I try
to post at least once a day in a
short form video format, so I'm
also trying to produce a short form video
that I can post anywhere
on Instagram, Tiktok and YouTube  Shorts
then I cover it on YouTube right now
I film twice a
week then we also have the app so
I have my own fitness app grow
with Anna I also try to film as much as
possible I would say
once or twice a week are also
workouts  and I started a podcast
wow okay okay so there's already
a lot of Kent portfolio which of these is most
important for your sales or for your financing
so which which channel I think
all channels are important right now because they
're so cross-cutting, clearly for
cooperation  At the moment, I think they are
still the most relevant when it comes to sales and because brand
cooperation is being done, they want to
be shown above all on YouTube
and on Instagram, or at the moment
most people still
choose Instagram, so that's still the case
always the most exciting for everyone tiktok
is still so well maybe join in
a little bit but still
Instagram is the most exciting
youtube is not that exciting for us
because we hardly place any advertising
so I don't speak in the
workouts and I want to  But it's not like there's
an interruption in the
meantime or that I'm
competing for something before or after, so that's why
Instagram
is the most exciting thing for the brands.
As a fitness influencer,
you also have sports clothing
sponsorship and athletes
Football in basketball that you're
okay now you're a Puma or Nike Adidas
athlete, you definitely have something like that,
so clothes are also the
most obvious thing for fitness creators because
you always wear them or generally everything
you always have at
Keim at the moment  but I had a long
cooperation and the hatade ended yes,
okay, which is true, so we are in
discussions about what do you have to do, what who is
anyone listening now about Adidas about Lulu Lemon
about and what do you have to do to improve
your fitness, for example
say in order to be able to equip you,
we're already talking about 100,000 that
it probably costs or oh
GT se does that thanks to my manager
you know he'll take care of it I
already know about it but I'm glad
that he's helping me with that  That's what
this type of partnership is, that's
the most important thing in the end, so
you say that's where the most comes from, so
any of them, it's also the most
authentic so I wear it I
wear it and it's it just fits really
well into my environment W was the
partner before  Well, in my opinion, I worked with Jim
Shark for a long time, very, very long, yes,
why, for a few years, at some point we could
n't agree anymore, then it expired.
I would say that both
sides, both Jim Shark and I, we
both fell in love with each other a little bit
Pages developed so developed in other
directions and then it was
just no longer a brand match and I
'm not now so that I say
okay, I'll just wear it now if you
get paid something for it,
it just developed like that, both of them
developed like that and it  Fits like that, I'm
still I think that was a
really, really good brand match for
the community too, it was a great fit but
I also come from
this muscular style of crossfits and
that's also something that they represent,
very muscular and that's just it
not like that anymore and then you need something
or I just don't think it's a
good fit anymore okay okay there is so you can
express your wishes here
you should get in touch somewhere you say here somehow if
someone from Adidas crossw is listening
or from Puma you are open to everything B
open to everything let's see okay
okay can you keep something like that up for a long time
so it's a job if you post so much content and
you can do it for another 20
years I hope I wish
I can keep it up for as long as possible
we also did recently  I
just talked about it and at 80 you're
still doing workouts. Film,
maybe, but I can also imagine other
workouts and other content formats. I just have
a lot of fun with podcasts. I then sit in
my home and just talk to
my community. Cooking recipes is
a lot of fun for me  There are so
many incredible opportunities in the
health sector, but I can
imagine your community. I mean,
I've been able to get to know a few
different influencers or
creators in different areas over the last few years
and what
strikes me is how hard it is for many of them
Community work so
sometimes lying in bed in the evening, I
think Caro Kauer or I even know
Kamuschka told me that they
then spend another hour or
an hour and a half at least
processing and answering the first wave of DMS
and
writing back something personal  and then at some point you
fall dead in bed and still haven't
answered everything,
but I think it's one of the
most important things, you make that
clear and how many hours do
you do DMS per day, sometimes more,
sometimes unfortunately it's a little
less  If it doesn't turn out that way,
but I've been trying
to sit there for as long as I can and also have a look
before I go to sleep.
Unfortunately, I don't try to do it quite as
often anymore, but I used to answer everything with voice
messages. I think that's what I think
Community gave me a lot
but unfortunately that doesn't happen that
often anymore but I really enjoy going for
walks and then I answer as
many as I can and your community is
above all women
your age or younger or men
or what have you  Yes, one of those who is
your community, what is the typical,
actually, of course, women, I also
have at the moment, so I'm dealing
with hormones and
female
hormones a lot and that's why of course,
a lot more women follow than
before, but it's mainly women in
my age and
25 to 31 okay and what about the
app so how many people use it then
also people who can do your workouts in the app
and and that is
paid for is
exactly a subscription model so you pay
monthly they are home workouts  We have
a lot of recipes in it and the
advantage is that you always
get workout plans given so you
know exactly what you have to do that
day
and it's mainly women. The
cool thing about the product is what I really
enjoy is that it's international
I mean, I don't have this line like
our merchandise stuff that we have,
okay, I, we, we
ship to Europe but not
outside of it and the app is worldwide,
that's really fun for me
yes for a
fitness crater in suggest how many
of these bottles have you already
sold so the bottles were our
bestsellers which was also really exciting that
we are now talking about such a
transparent bottle that fits about
1 liter or something like that
one liter one liter  such a relatively large
bottle with a handle and a
flip cap and I
told you the story about it earlier, it was
on tiktok back then and it's still
a real hype on tiktok and
there's this trend on tiktok, this dead
girl trend, you know that one  okay and
so dead girl everyone wants
to be dead girl whatever that means for
each individual but dead girl just gets
up in the morning and has her
water bottle with her and yes that's why it was
such a hype product and they jumped on the hype,
yes  and we are
currently producing again after now it says
stay hydrated girl
and with boy soon for boys and they
are also but how much how much did
you order the first batch
the first batch was
four digits four digits ordered yes al
means we are talking about 2 3000  Bottles yes
and then there is a second batch come
in different colors and without a
girl so also for men that's hot you
dare then you're already beyond
your reach to sell say 20 30 000
bottles is possible so
stop at the bottles bestseller product
I a lot a lot possible yes we also other
products and I also think it's really cool
and really exciting because we
try out a lot of different things we
journals were one of the first
products diaries diaries exactly in
German then the bottles mats at the very
beginning the first product that  We had
mini bands resistance bands
for training so we try
an incredible amount of ash costs a
bottle I think it's really cool what what
does it cost in 1990 1990 plus shipping costs
and then I have them made somewhere in Asia
and then whoever is
sent directly to the or  So no,
we have our warehouse in
Germany, the warehouse is in
Germany and from there it
is shipped from there. That's where we
store all the products, so
the bottle, our journal, the mats,
everything in the future, I hope
that too  we have everything in stock
and can then send out bundles
and have you
done such a job yourself with shopify or or or
or okay so shopify solution exactly exactly
I used to have like what's the
name of the other platform help me with
that  Jumps where you can do shops like that
wocommerce wommerce that's exactly what I did back
then alone with Erin
I can remember with the
mini ribbons and also sent from home
but bottles are the
best-selling thing, so to speak, more than
ribbons in any case and  That's also
a nobrainer like we had
back then with the clothes, that's
just every day in my story
all the time and that's why the community
sees it every day that will be there
safe on the day Zick News where
is the bottle  How can I get
to the bottle? What do you think is the
size of your community? So we
now have the reach and the
number of subscribers on the platform. There
are also
some that have been inactive for a long time, so
how much will you say are really
like that?  People who are already
following you regularly every month, how many
are there? We're talking
about millions, we're talking about
100,000's
define but then there
is also the YouTube community,
so there are different
platforms that we are talking about that are completely
different and it also depends on
what is happening on YouTube, for example
when I have a workout challenge for
a week where I say okay, everyone, come on, let's
do it  now every day together this
and that and that so a workout every day
we drink our 3 liters of water
then we are much more active than in
the quieter times exactly it is always
different but tell me
to make something tangible so storyvws how much
you have  you there,
I'm just thinking about what digit
range, so definitely more than
10%.  So if 1.2 million more 10% that
's over 100,000 W definitely definitely
more than 10%.  Okay,
and I mean, we're also doing
events now, so that means we can
meet you live and in real life, how many people come
there, so we've now had
two larger events, so the whole
series of events that we do is called hit
the road hit with 2i  for our hit
workouts and we had two larger
events in Berlin at the Station Berlin
that were now this year on
September 30th there were around 400 we had around
400 people have to buy a ticket and
then you can train with it then
do big things  Training for 400 people
exactly and I wouldn't say
big training, but we, yeah, it was
awesome, so we set it up a bit
like a festival, that is,
we had Sony Music, for example, which was
there last year and then we had
artists who performed  That year
we suddenly had cheerleaders who
danced with us. Yes, it's a bit like
a festival with brands, so with
stands with
brands, a whole day, you go there
and then you're at the
growing pineapple day in Berlin, so to speak, 400
people  and how much did a ticket like that cost
that year? There were different
price categories because you could also
buy the math tea with it so you could
buy a premium ticket in
the first rows with a mat that
was really cool €40 50 probably or a
little more more okay actually  and
with math then a little more
so then
manauet with math it was definitely
over 100 okay okay that's
quite nice no me yes yes but you also
got food you got drink
yes that means there you are  really
extremely business-minded to develop all these ideas
or do you do it or are you
super deep into it that you say hey
look I should have that how
strong are you an entrepreneur how strong
are you a creator of the percent what do
you want to
say I think it's very important  So I
'm definitely a creator, you have to
honestly say I'm a creat creator,
the creative head Marcel does
a lot with strategy with numbers, that's
incredible. Ideas come partly
from him, partly from someone
else in the team or from me and
then you bet  So together the event
series hit the road was really fun, we
sat at dinner and then I remember
we walked this place in Berlin three times
and thought, okay,
how cool would it be if we did these big
fitness events, but
what?  is a festival and how cool would
it be to work with Sony Music and how
cool cool would it be to
have a tour bus and drive from city to city
and then we now have with
Mercedes-Benz we
got two cars  and we drove from city
to city so hot how much
sten was then we were first
in I think Vienna Munich Berlin then
again and then Cologne so that means
what you D station that you have in
the form in four or five other
cities  still done a bit smaller a
bit smaller yes okay exactly but
purely theoretically you could really
go on tour and go to 20 30 places
probably yes we
also talk about it sometimes how cool it would be
to do a bit of something internationally too
we have done work events
internationally but  always with
brands we did one in LA that
was also the cool thing about the international community and then suddenly
yes, your podcast is also in English, oh
really okay and you don't have
any h or do you speak
English as a native speaker or with an
accent or no  native speaker
actually Austrian with a
super dialect so really dialect now
especially High German but if you
do a podcast then you still have a little
German-Austrian accent
probably no so then it's
completely English but but so
you can't hear it anymore that you then
people think no on the podcast you  If you're
an American or you're English, a
lot of people know that I'm from Germany.
It's easier, a lot of people celebrate it
and learn
this new language together with me and of course there are a
lot of things that I can't
think of, but they all know it
simple but a lot of things are
easier for me to notice in
English then it's
great if you've been learning for a long time or
so clearly probably with the whole
developer and programming there
everything happens in very English
probably not maybe because
I myself have a lot of content
English is exactly what the whole team consumes.
English Berlin is also very
international and I think in the long term
I would really like to position myself
internationally a bit more. There are
creators in the USA or somewhere who
inspire you a little bit. I can
see that  A lot of them do it
well, there are a lot of creators from whom I
get a lot of inspiration, but there
are always such small parts. Now there's no one where
I say it's like 100 per cent.
I'd like to take over everything, wow, there's
a lot, I like very authentic vloggers
from the past  Don't
you know Emma Chamberlin? Yes, or Casy
Neister are simply vloggers
where I look at individual things
and think wow, cool, authentic
in front of the camera, super easy,
so super cool and easy to do
I think a lot of J shadyy in the
podcast area is great mhm that's a
monk a little di super vi but I
think it's very cool K I learn a lot
from the but so individual ones where you always
pick out a little something and so what do
you think if you continue to grow now
Then it would lead to you
simply implementing even more or
reaching even more people, so what
drives you the most are
many different things, so what
you get back from the community,
not in the form of money,
not in the form of sales, but just like that
this feeling that I'm doing something that gives
me an incredible amount of joy and it gives
people
something. The team
behind the scenes also gives me an
incredible amount, as I said before,
that I've been able to create something, that
we can now be a team and  We
can all make a living from it, that gives me an
incredible amount and I hope that we
can do this for many, many more years. You also travel a lot,
so you already told me in the
vprch, now somehow South Korea
Australia, so you spend the winter
more often  in the southern hemisphere yes
definitely so Berlin is
gray gray and dark and
gloomy in winter no we're trying to escape
and then just so that you can
somehow maintain this content yourself
I
also want to give people something positive when I'm
in  I'm in such a low mood
I can't I ca
n't make him believe anything positive I can't I
want to stay authentic somehow and
then yes I'm a summer person too
and then summer is definitely a
much better fit and then you're flying to South Korea
there's actually no summer right now
No sense at all but it's just a
stopover on the way to
Australia exactly and what's going on in South Korea
or why are you there I've never been to South Korea
but I have an incredibly
great interest in South Korea
also in the fitness area I find
it so exciting  I also find
video ideas for V videos for my own content, for example, so you
kind of want to, you kind of need
new ideas and now when I'm
sitting at home at some point I run out of ideas.
I always need a lot of
different input and traveling helps me
unbelievable and I think there's
so much crazy stuff going on in South Korea too, there's
so many new
ideas coming up, I'm really looking forward to it because
you're actually like, let's say a
fitness expert, now
I'm really qualified, I mean,
you have the range
Obviously,
but you're not somehow
qualified or or somehow there is
no
training at all or so where do
you get the certainty that these
are actually exercises that are
good for people in the long term? I did
CrossFit for a long time and I  I was
also working as a CrossFit coach at the time.
I was
doing this training back then, which is
exactly what I was teaching in the CrossFit
area in my CrossFit box back then,
which means what I already
shared back then was
still related to my CrossFit training
yes yes okay but that means your your
if you try to deconstruct your success a
little bit where does it come
from how can that be if you
wanted that too now then you've already
caught a few trends so
I'm really into the CrossFit trend  brought to the forefront or
that so that that
somehow that you timed it exactly by
chance probably that was just a
very very small niche that
had to be covered somehow on YouTube
but no one covered it at the time
and that was also luck as many
people believe they are trying to do  similar
career as you have and and ca
n't do it so now you're
one of in football you say you do
n't know if one in 1000
comes to the Bundesliga who somehow
starts the game of football in Germany in the club of the six year olds
like that  With you, what do you want to
say? I think that a
lot of people are trying it. I think that
a lot of people are trying it, but
maybe my first tip is always
okay, yes. L just put something up every day. That
's always the first sentence I say
But it's also important that you
still post high-quality content
and offer added value in some way, which
means that many people might post something
that doesn't have that much added value yet
and that's why I think
a lot of people try it, but if the
strategy fails a lot of them, then a lot of them aren't
disciplined enough  I really
have the feeling that a lot of people are
still trying to become big on Instagram,
but it's just many years too late,
as some people still do
Our SEO pages are on Google and that
's just not as easy as it was
years ago, so you don't need
the right distribution platform at the
right time, so for me Instagram is
still
a really cool platform, especially with Res  to grow so
if you have cracked res like that, that's
something, that's the number a
tip for Reals, what do you have to
do right? A
little bit different works for everyone. For me it's
always the first few seconds
point be they have to be
there the first few seconds have to be a
hassle because otherwise the whole
video doesn't work it doesn't matter what comes in second
10 if the beginning isn't there
people click away you also have to
imagine how often we sit like that and
scroll  through and it's all
ALIVE so quickly and when do you really get
stuck on a video, you have to
figure that out for yourself and
it's different for a lot of different
target groups, you have to
find out for yourself how important it is
that you yourself are in the
fitness area, so to speak  I have a body that
is also believable, for example.
When I go to fitness, there
is a trainer who now has a
stomach and somehow has no idea how to walk.
I say he's the
right person to teach me something.
I don't know. In your case, it's probably the same way.
You need
a six-pack or something  You don't
show it, but you need
a good body yourself
or doesn't it matter? I thought that
was always the criterion for me for a long time
and I thought you had to look like that
and be a fitness creator
I think that
maybe that has changed, I don't know
anymore or whether it's just me or just me,
but I think it's totally
changed and what I see as a trend right now
is exactly the opposite and
I think so I think that  That's
just how people are developing who
are more real and show things that
maybe aren't so perfect, they're
growing extremely right now and I see it
that way too and I sometimes show things,
for example the issue with women so blebauch if
I have something like that then I'll show it too
or  what other things are blemished
skin or yes there are a few issues
that just bother me personally and
I share them and it's often
even better received so somehow
this pose with like this I look so
perfect and that's not possible  More in
my opinion it doesn't work anymore even
if I try it's in the
people on social media are currently cringe
and n the word okay and what what yes
so that means BB is something one time
that then goes away again but is there
any problem  Parts where men say
I make people strong I also
somehow do
n't have it if I don't sit like that then
I don't immediately recognize the
fitness deficits so of course I have
my problems
Maybe you don't
see it, but I see it and I think that's what it's like
when I look in the
mirror and I see something and it
bothers me, that's the real
problem and every one of us has it. I
think you can do it like that  be perfect on the outside
everyone has their own problems and
I think it's important to share that people
talk about it openly how did it take you to get
from your very
slim K bit to the
CrossFit body you're
showing off now, how long was that so first of all
me  I'm incredibly satisfied, I'm
grateful for the body I have because
it's healthy because I can do everything
I want to do, but it's
still clear that it's such a
lifelong journey, I think, until it goes on and on and
that's a good thing because
if it does  somehow it would end then it would
n't be so cool but from this very very
thin first to this being strong
and now I'm not that
strong anymore so now I do my
home workouts and endurance is
more relevant for me right now but back then it was
just  Building muscle has also taken
a few years,
so CrossFit, you also do a
lot of it, so it's nutrition-related now, so
S also supplements it quite well, so
nutrition definitely
from the start, or have you
always noticed, okay, come on,
I've got one thing under control  Now
I'm also doing a bit of
nutrition-related stuff and top so maybe
nutrition, that's a topic where I
'm not qualified, for example, so I
wouldn't
put out nutrition plans or give out nutrition tips.
I
have it in Canada but that's my
nutrition expert, for example, in the app too  If
there's anything in the app, if there are any
tips in it, if there are any
nutritional things or recipes in it,
it's all checked
and approved by her and it's also in
my podcast, for example, if I talk about
nutrition topics then
she supports me and the advice
comes from her  and not from me but
that's so cool because then I can
learn together with the community about
Jennifer. I've now somehow
understood about you, you're also or it would be
another one of those growth levers
that you've found is like
making reaction videos  I don't know about other
food trends or fitness
trends, so you just go
for it when others do something and
comment and try it out
yourself to see if it really works that easily.
I've
seen you
build melons like that  sozag with a
lot of fruit in it and so you have to take
a look at it's super
melon vide so it's also such
a lever that you can say
okay, I've found that out for myself
that it works well if I
imitate something like that and so so so  reactions do
oh definitely so these are
the recipes we're talking about now
recipes healthy recipes of course that fits
perfectly into my environment I know my
fitness target group is
also interested in recipes that's
a
nobiner like that and then just like that  the reactions
This is a content format that I
discovered for myself that
worked well once and once you
have something like this that works well
I think it is very important that you
maybe try it again, again
and again and again a second time
Maybe it doesn't work so well but if it
works again the third time
then it's definitely a
content format that works well for me
and I'll continue to do that.
How far can you stretch? So now
you have fitness food. What's next?
Now it's
kind of close if you're a female, so to speak. There's
probably a lot
more coming from you, it's the
right keyword, so what suits
my target group and me, so it's
one of the biggest topics in many different areas  The thing that
hardly anyone talks about is
these female hormone things, periods,
hardly anyone talks about it, but it's
such a viral topic so when I
post something about it,
I would say 99% of the time it's in a positive
direction because everyone can understand it
and everyone is there in some way
needs help or everyone
needs lessons in some way so many people do
n't even know about it even though I'm 28
and I'm currently learning things about it.
No one ever taught us that at school
but that's an area that I
would like to get more involved in, so
everything  Women's
health, yes, fashion goes
well, of course, everything with skin care,
hair care, everything like that,
you're already doing that too,
partnerships like that with skin care and
I mean there's a whole
range of brands from
Barbara Sturm a while ago who probably know them
also and so
I know Alpizin, they
also have Dr Wolf a whole portfolio
of creams so that's already
a huge market so you're already in
various partnerships, we've
done that, we're not doing any at the moment
Cooperation in that direction I
also find it difficult with main
care, for example, it always takes a very
long time, so in general all
the cooperation we do
always takes a very long time because I
want to test it for a very long time and especially with
main care you have to test it for a really long time
If I say okay, that's
super good and I would like to
recommend it to others and you can
create something together with the brand and do something cool then
at the moment there's nothing in that direction
but I could imagine doing that in the
future  You could
actually build your own products if that
works, that's probably really
attractive or I think
building an international skin care industry is
still a bigger
business than selling drinking bottles now. It definitely
makes sense from
the perspective that it's something you always do  You have
to buy it again, so
you have to buy the bottle once and then it doesn't
fit, so now it's not a product that
you can buy again and again. GL,
the prices are just super high  I
see that I just have to be so
convinced of it and that has to be the case, especially
with skin, that it gets on the skin because
people have to be
tested for a really long time and I would have that
checked out somehow by so many doctors
and there are no certifiers yet
Consideration, but I think that would be
something like that of the growth areas
that are now open to you, there are many
different areas that could
be one of them, what else is there, so what are
you thinking about, what else could you
do, wow, that could also be more
in other lifestyle things  it
could also go in the
direction of nutritional supplements
it could go in many, many different
directions also somehow at home
if at some point I
decide to do more at home somehow furnishing
transport environment so
actually what what used to be women's
magazine so when I was, so to speak
Somehow I started at the publishing house and gave
me Brigitte and other
women's magazines. Everything that was in there is
now your account,
so you are now the Brigitte
of the next generation, if you
like. You used to, too. I also
bought magazines and read so much
Nowadays you don't have time and quotation marks
anymore, what do you do? You put
your AirPods in and want to
listen to someone
talking about it, that's usually the case with videos
too, for example, so long ago videos vlogs I do
n't really watch them anymore, I
just listen but  I think that's how
I see the trend, I
also see everything going in that direction, that's the way it has to be. You
always have to be
able to do several things at the same time. I want to
vacuum, but at the same time I want to
listen to Brigitte's things. Yes, I think that's
the direction it's going to go  because
for you P reif I now know her a
little better, I've also done podcast
events more often than not, she's
somehow a competitor or role model for you
or do you say that's somehow I'm
2 now, she's 10 or how do
you look at P reif I have  She
actually met Heer three or four times,
also once quite funny in the
airport, completely by chance. We
met before
in Austria, that was also
a very funny story.
We were at the same event, that was
exactly at the Stangelwirt  and then I came
from my flight and thought okay, I
'll go for a little walk
and with my cell phone because everyone
was already ready for dinner and I
went for a little walk and she apparently had the
same thought, so we did  met us for the
first time, yes, I think she's
really nice, so it was really cool, I have to
say for me too, she used to be
a bit of a
role model, so it definitely
pushed me, I found it really
exciting what she built up for
herself  has built up and no always so
I still think that S that's what
she's built up
so you know you're now also
competitive or I mean she wants
people's attention
too but I think as I said that
's it  so much space for everyone so why does
there have to be one and the other ca
n't exist that's so much space for
everyone I don't see any competition
coming D still think about new things every day where
you think somehow human they are
so similar to me  Now in your space there
are so many different
creators at the moment, just like you
said, there are so many different ones coming every day.
Suddenly
you see someone still has a huge
reach and I've never
seen it before, but no, I think so
There is room for everyone in
sports and fitness, for example, and maybe
I can get a little
more of what I need today from one,
but tomorrow I'll need a little
from the other. I don't think I can do that kind of
analysis  how loyal
your community is, how long it has been like
now, you've been there for three years
now, three and a half years, which means
it's not that long yet, but if
you look at whether these are people
who have been there for three years or not  Do
you also have one like that? So people who say
okay, now I've
looked at it for half a year and now I've had enough
with Anna. Now
I have to look for something new or stay
loyal. There are definitely people who will
probably drop out even then, but
There are also people who have been there from the very
beginning, especially YouTube, so
YouTube I have to say, they are so
established and they stay there so they
stay for a really long time and we always
have one in
every million or half a million
we celebrate together  And there are people who are
already waiting for these celebrations every time,
so
celebrating community. Celebrating community means
our workouts, we then do
workouts together or livestams,
exactly okay, old people, I think
sport is also a topic that
connects extremely well, so me  I think
right now the sports community fitness
community yes they will
stick with it and let's say people have already
reported that they
want to do fitness rules and SAS with you
so we have a food cooperation that
we recently did with Coro
Coro Cafe yes  the online dro of course
are involved in a very small part with om they
have these in Berlin
yes thank you very much but they have these do you
know these cor CAF have you ever been to
me and I know about the project of course I definitely
have to go to one
Come on, we have this Rainbow Bowl, there's
a bowl to eat, that was the last
project that we did together in the food sector, it's
really cool, that's
hot, you don't really have
all the cooperation yet, everything that
could be done in terms of monetization is still there
pretty much open actually we
have a few long-term partners at the
moment so who is your biggest partner at the
moment I'll just say that everyone
is on, for example, a partner Withings it's a
big partner alsor yes exactly so
everything is long-term
stuff we
have my protein we have
waterdrop  Yes,
we've done quite a lot of music, it's a
good fit because they
're also Austrian, but we don't have
so I don't do that much and when
I do something, it's always
long-term, it's always two
years or longer, so it's always
In the long term, I also think it's super important
at the moment. I also think that the
things like before, once you've
done it, I have no idea in 2019, that
you say okay, I'll do a
story now and put a discount code in it,
it just doesn't work anymore and  That's a
good thing, so I always think you
have to use something in the long term every day
and convey it authentically and
then the community celebrates okay, but
that means in the end the platform revenue
I don't think is
that important at the beginning, so YouTube
implements something like that  comes in from the classic
YouTube advertising inheritance. I think that's
comparatively low compared
to the collaborations. No, that
's also important, so one of the
biggest things is YouTube, but now it's
not on Instagram and TikTok, so
YouTube is the only platform that's
relevant for me  it's okay financially
okay oh cooperation now so from the
platform of the say if we
meet fully now and the one who
comes back in I don't know 3 vi years where
many percent of that have you already
achieved so what do you think of if
that then 34  Years are 100% and you
stay healthy, everything continues to work out
where come where are you currently so that's
called growing pineapple I
think you're really happy inside I
want to keep growing there
's always something and I think it's in D  For six
years now, I wish that
this urge is
still there to double or
triple what you think is
possible
But
you always have to differentiate, so
yes, reach is one thing, but who
are these people behind it?
It's super important to me that the reach
as it grows is also community reach,
so I want to continue to
do events and I want to continue to have the events soul
filled, that is  now
just reach reach
reach W that's not the
goal now you have to make halls irw you have to do
so on so I don't know big
maybe yes um what's it called in
Berlin there are the Mercedes-Benz
or something like that and the arena there  you the
yes yes on aner strahlauerer the
huge thing yes maybe maybe
you can imagine that you feel such a
huge hall and that is that is
the goal maybe expand the team a
little bit create even more
areas of responsibility I see myself
in three to  four years okay and
at some point there will also be an option to somehow
say now I've earned so much from it,
I've taken care of that now I'll
just let it go again, do
n't think about it like that, so at the moment
definitely not, it's also incredibly fun for me  I
enjoy producing little videos here with my cell phone,
it's incredibly
fun and if you
can generate added value and help someone with it, that's
cool and I hope that I'm
still doing this in D years or in 5 years,
who knows what it will be
It's awesome, so thank you for letting us stop you
from your classic work for a day to
do some fitness exercise videos, thank you for
letting me be here, so really, really
cool, I'm happy to
invite you to do a few pull-ups. Do
you do pull-ups, I've already seen them and
they are  dipbahn and klimzü I have
n't done one for a long time but if
you do klimzü how much can you do
I don't know, I used to do a
lot of
klimzü important but
you used to do a few times or something like that oh
I even managed more, well
then  Can try it out oh my God, it's
okay, thank you very much, come, thank you very much, thank you, thank you,
very much, ciao ciao ciao ciao
[applause]
[music]
bye